بعد نحوي اسبوعين من التصريحات والتصريحات
المضاده سوليدار بيد الروس الجيش
الاوكراني اعلن انسحابه من المدينه بحسب
المتحدث العسكري شرق البلاد لم يحدث تاريخ
الانسحاب لكنه يقول انه تلا معارك صعبه
على مدى اشهر وانه كان منظما بحيث لم
تتعرض قوه بلاده للحصار او الاسر الى جانب
القتال كانت المدينه الواقعه في منطقه
دنيتك شرقاء اوكرانيا محور العديد من
التصريحات الروسيه بالاستيلاء عليها وما
قابلها من نفي الاوكراني وصولا الى ظهور
زعيم الانفصالي موال روسيا فيها وقبل ذلك
نشو مرتزقه
تسجيلا يظهر بعض العناصر وهم يتجولون في
المدينه وير الجيش الروسي
المجاوره التي يسعى منذ الصيف الى السيطره
عليها والتي تشهد مناطقها الشماليه حاليا
معارك فقط فيما لا يتفق الخبراء على اهميه
المدينه الاستراتيجيه فمثلا يعتبر معهد
دراسه الحرب ومقره الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ان الانسحاب الاوكراني لا يشكل
تطورا مهما من الناحيه العمليه